which activities are the most effective
at different levels of competence in a
language so the relationship between
learning activities and where we are in
the language I'm often asked what do you
do to learn a language what do I do when
I'm starting out what do I do if I want
to break through the plateau we are all
at different levels in the language and
therefore to some extent our learning
activities will vary what is my
situation because I can only talk about
what I do so first of all when it comes
to the sort of levels in a language
there are some recognized reference
points like the common European
framework of reference which has six
levels of skill you know A1 A2 which is
a beginner B1 B2 which is intermediate
and C1 C2 which is Advanced and these
can be for writing for speaking for
reading for listening to some extent it
gives you an idea of what that level
corresponds to but I have a lot of
trouble with that I prefer to see our
levels in a language are sort of on a
Continuum when we start we're very much
in influenced by our own language we're
sort of translating from our own
language structures that we think in
terms of our from our own language and
gradually over time we sort of get more
comfortable in this other language some
people talk about inter languages sort
of a language that we use when we're
sort of in between the new language and
languages that we already know I don't
think that's particularly helpful I
think we just gradually get better and
if they're sort of infinite steps on
this gradient and also we might be
better in listening or in reading or in
speaking and so to arbitrarily say you
know I'm a B2 or I'm a B1 I'm reluctant
to do that and while I say that it is a
handy reference so I always think in
terms of getting to sort of a B2 level
which to me is sort of fluent to the
extent that I can use the language
comfortably knowing that I'm going to
make mistakes knowing that there are
going to be some things that I don't
understand but I'm communicating
comfortably to me that's sort of your
launch now whereas beginner to me either
you are total beginner like zero and
I'll tell you what I'll do when I'm at
zero or you're still very much
struggling to get a toe hold in the
language that's the sort of beginner
then you've got B2 which to me is sort
of the launching point and then
somewhere in between those two is the
sort of B1 genuine intermediate level in
Canada for whatever reason they came up
with 12 levels they call it the Canadian
language benchmarks on the theory that
you can tie a particular job to level
five and they try to describe in great
detail what you are able to do in a
particular level and I think this is
also quite unrealistic you know
sometimes we do better than at other
times depending on what we've been
exposed to we might do better in certain
types of contexts than in others it's
more or less the same idea we go from
nothing from zero to being launched and
if we are a non-native speaker there
will still be some Jagged edges in our
language skill even after we're launched
and and we just continue to progress as
long as we keep studying so when I'm a
complete beginner and I might just
demonstrate this sometime at link and
because that's what I use now but before
link what I would do is I would go out
and buy two or three different starter
books teach yourself living language
colloquial
they're all the same in my opinion they
have a little lesson they have a
vocabulary list for the lesson and they
have some grammatical explanations that
you kind of look at and you work your
way through the lesson and if you listen
to that and then the next one and the
next one and then you go back to the
first one and you keep doing that
eventually you start to get a bit of a
sense of the language of course by doing
three different books I'm getting the
same material from three different
sources it's what I often refer to as
grazing you're kind of covering the same
material in different ways that's a very
effective way to learn because if we are
constantly using the same book and
trying to force the same material into
our brains the brain starts to lose
interest as Spitzer always says the
brain likes repetition but the brain
likes novelty so you keep it fresh by
changing the source but you don't want
to cover two broad a range of vocabulary
at the beginning you want it to be more
or less high frequency vocabulary so
that there will be enough repetition
that you can kind of get somewhere I
think any learning contact we have we
want to have enough of a mix of the
familiar with the new so that we're not
like everything is brand new and where
we have the feeling that we're trying to
learn things and no sooner have we
grabbed it then it's gone you know and
that's how we designed the mini stories
that there's in each lesson the same
verbs the same words repeat five times
we need this level of repetition at the
beginning and the traditional starter
books that I used to use don't have
enough repetition because they take you
from the train station to the doctor's
office to the hotel lobby or Customs or
whatever they usually do in those books
so as a beginner I like to be in content
with high frequency words ideally with a
lot of repetition and I end up listening
over and over and over again until I
start to get a toehold in the language
that is the pattern and even after
having completed one of these Beginner
Books where they promise you that you'll
be at B1 or B2 that's not the case
because we require so much input in the
language and to the extent that we have
high frequency vocabulary that means
we're left with a lot of lower frequency
vocabulary that we still don't know and
therefore we're very limited in what we
can listen to and read so it doesn't
take you to B2 or B1 but it takes you
maybe to an A2 level in the language if
we stay with the common European
framework now if I'm going to study a
language that I'm at an intermediate
level in there are two possible
situations either I'm in the midst of
learning that language or it's a
language that I learned before and I
left it for a while and I'm going back
to it the approach is essentially the
same I want to go to content that is a
little bit challenging but interesting
to me some of that which I then vary
with something like the many stories
with a lot of repetition I am
particularly fond of sentence review now
at link because now that I know more
about how the brain learns languages
when we study sentence by sentence we
are focusing more on that particular
sentence and we can hear the sentence
again and we're looking at words within
that sentence and then we review the
words immediately after that sentence so
there's a certain level of frequency a
certain level of familiar things and all
of that helps to get those neurons
firing together and then in the sentence
review we are forced to reassemble the
sentence which means drawing on our it's
not exactly our memory because we're
looking at the words there but we're
having to form a sentence the words are
have been scrambled we have to put them
back together again in their proper
order it's a very good discipline for
become coming familiar with the
structure of the language and also sort
of renewing our acquaintance with
vocabulary that we have just met so I
find that a tremendous exercise even in
the initial stages but particularly as
we progress to kind of get that feel
that you're getting a good sense of how
the language works I don't spend all my
time doing that because I spend a lot of
time just playing listening and reading
you know more of a top-down thing but I
find that that nuts and bolts bits and
pieces exercise is very effective that's
kind of at the intermediate level but
once you get past that now you're into
audiobook territory you're into reading
books you're into extensive exposure to
the language and that's the only way
you're going to take yourself from that
I have studied this language and I can
do a limited number of things in the
language to being really comfortable and
being a smooth speaker writer and to be
able to understand movies and so forth
you have to consume a lot of it and
that's the extensive stage that's the
reward every stage in the process is a
reward I love doing my sentence review
even as a beginner or as an intermediate
learner but then eventually when I'm
able to enjoy books and movies and so
forth that's where the Big Payback comes